[Music]
every one and it's a real pleasure for
me to be here and be able to share with
you a little bit of our stories NHS
Blood transplants and our journey of
process automation NHS Blood and
transplant is one of about 450
organizations together with seven and a
half thousand family practices but
collectively make up the United Kingdom
National Health Service it's a service
that provides health care services to
every resident of the United Kingdom
free at the point of use and with an
annual spend of about a hundred and
twenty billion pounds and with 1.3
million employees the NHS is the fifth
largest employer in the world after the
US Department of Defense the Chinese
People's Liberation People's Liberation
Army wal-mart and McDonald's so it's a
huge operation to provide that health
care service NHS PT's role in that
service really forth into three areas we
are responsible for providing a safe and
reliable supply of blood to every
hospital in England working with just
under a million blood donors every year
to process about 1.7 million donations
or six thousand units of blood a day to
service the needs of hospitals
throughout the UK
sorry throughout England our diagnostic
and therapeutic services function is an
area where we carry out a range of
specialized testing for the NHS
specialised blood testing we carry out
immunology testing tissue typing and a
range of services that the NHS would not
otherwise have and in that function we
also provide about 11,000 or 12,000 at
tissue implants every year and we manage
about 50% of the UK stem cell donations
and we were the first blood service in
the world to start genetic sequencing of
our stem cell donors in order to enable
better matching of donors to recipient
and then we have our organ donation and
transplantation function where we work
with families at what for them is
incredibly tragic and difficult time to
have a conversation about whether or not
their loved one who has just died or is
dying would have wanted to be an organ
donor and if they are to make
arrangements for their organs to be
retrieved and transplanted enabling four
and a half thousand transplants to take
place in the UK every year but the
transplant waiting list is six and a
half thousand people and therefore on
average three people die every day in
the UK waiting for an organ transplant
and that's a problem and that's the
problem I want to talk to you a little
bit about this afternoon and how we have
attempted to address that we attempt to
address that by working very closely
with transplant surgeons and with
clinicians to improve the organ a
location processes and to improve the
organ occasion schemes to balance for
sometimes competing priorities of equity
the principle of equal access to the
transplant to a transplant opportunity
utility the idea that we will make
maximum use of the organs that are
available and fairness the idea that if
someone's been waiting for a long time
they should probably have a degree of
priority on the waiting list but as we
make changes to those allocation schemes
we hit upon a problem and that problem
is that they're becoming increasingly
complex what you're seeing on the screen
are just some of the factors that are
taken into consideration in that liver
allocation scheme as it is currently
being developed they take into account
physical factors about the donor and the
potential recipient they take into
account the clinical situation of the
donor and the recipient
and they take into account the geography
where each of them is based and those
factors aren't static they change over
time and we learn more and more over
time about how we could actually
allocate more opens more effectively in
order to try and ensure that everyone
has the best chance possible of
receiving a life-saving transplant in
our existing systems however the
complexity was very hard to manage our
systems were developed largely about 15
years ago they were built as most
applications were at that particular
point in time and the reality is no one
really knows the intricacies of those
systems anymore a lot of that knowledge
is gone that leads us to another problem
the time when this is all happening and
how the decision process works because
organ-donation almost never to be
happens in the middle of the night very
often and it's a very time-sensitive
process we have people who have to make
decisions about who the recipient or the
potential recipient should be which
order we should offer the organs out to
the different transplant centers in
order for them to make a decision about
which recipient should receive those
organs and they have to do that in the
shortest possible time because the
longer they take to get through the
offering process the longer that family
is waiting to know what's going to
happen in terms of donation and that
process is at least was at least 96
steps
long and what you're seeing on the
screen are just some of the workflow
that used to apply to that process and
every box on the screen that is that is
coated red or colored red sorry is a
step in that process that was a manual
step that are highly skilled officers in
our duty office had to work through for
every single donor that we had and the
third problem that the observance of
long you might have spotted in the last
few slides is across the bottom the time
that it took to make changes to our
systems because of the nature of the
systems because of the complexity of the
systems and the complexity of the
workflow it took us on average about two
years to implement a new organ
allocation scheme that's two years when
we could have had a more effective
scheme where we could have saved and
improved more life so that's the problem
that we wanted to solve it was a problem
that was exacerbated by the fact there
were always exceptions and some of those
exceptions we couldn't even manage in
our systems so we had a workaround
and that workaround with a white board
in the office where we put the name or
the details of every urgent transplant
patient on the waiting list these are
the patients who have they didn't
receive a transplant most probably would
not live for very much longer
and every time one of these patients got
transplanted or every time one of these
patients sadly died somebody in the
office had to go and wipe off that
particular line and re transcribe every
line below it upon the list so that we
always had an up-to-date list of urgent
transplant patients this was not a
process that we were very happy with
it's not a process that we felt was safe
and it wasn't a process that was
enabling us to do our jobs as
effectively as we might that's the
problem that we then came and spoke to
IBM about and in the course of those
conversations we stumbled on three
products that collectively we thought
would help us to address those problems
blueworks live the operational decision
manager and the business process manager
blueworks live enables us to have a
conversation with the people who are
actually working in the office about the
processes that they are actually
following to map them out in a way that
they can understand and interpret them
and then to look to take that forward
into some sort of automation tool the
operational decision manager has enabled
us to start to build flexible rules
rules that we know we can change quickly
because we understand how the rules are
constructed within the context of a
decision manager product and the
business process manager gives us a
supportive workflow that our staff need
to automate that process and enable them
to get on with the job of talking to the
transplant centers and engaging and
liaison with our staff in the donation
hospitals to make sure that the families
have the best possible experience of
donations when that is a genuine
possibility and all of those products
we've chosen to implement using the on
cloud version the reasons that's quite
straightforward I do not want to have a
whole team of people worrying about how
many virtual machines we need in order
to operate a particular piece of
software I do not want to have a whole
team of people spending
all their time worrying about how many
or what particular variety of
infrastructure we need to buy tomorrow
our expertise what we know how to do is
how to take technology and apply it to
what we do best
saving and improving the lives of others
through better more effective
organization schemes so this is what it
starts to look like now on October 25th
last year we went live with the first of
our systems our heart allocation scheme
and we allocated the first heart in the
world using a cloud-based system tools
that I've just talked about we started
that process from scratch in March of
last year and we implemented it in
October that two-year cycle was reduced
to just six months and in that process
we automated about 40 of the 96 steps
that were previously involved in the
process a significant reduction in the
number of manual steps that our staff
have to go through in that time critical
moment for me the real beauty of it was
that we were able to do that by
integrating the the new products to work
very closely with our existing
applications so that our staff didn't
have a fundamentally different
experience when they move from an old
application to a new application the two
came together sure they got a much
better looking feel but they didn't have
to go hopping between different
applications through their work they
were able to you - all in one seamlessly
integrated environment making use of our
existing on-premise capability and the
cloudscape of relating the cloud systems
we use the platform because it wanted
repeatability and reusability much of
what we have developed for our heart
allocation schemes can be reused in all
of the other allocation schemes that
we're now on the process of developing
we wanted a platform because it allows
us to iterate and improve over time we
know the platform will get better and we
don't have to do all of the work to make
the platform get better
we've got other people the good people
in IBM who are helping us with that and
hopefully improving the platform as we
go and we were able therefore to map our
end-to-end user journey
and to build it all the way out as part
of our process of digitization we have
now digitized everything from the point
that our specialist nurses approach the
family in the intensive care department
right through to the point that we offer
the organs for transplant to the
transplant centers and we're not
stopping there later this year we will
implement a new liver allocation scheme
which we anticipate will save 50 lives
every year because of the better
allocation that we are able to influence
we will deploy a digitized transplant
waiting list to enable the transplant
centers to manage their patients
digitally and update the information
regularly so it is current as possible
throughout the process going back to
that threefold piece about what process
automation means for us it is about that
discovery piece it's about being able to
work with our users or our customers
understand what they need engage with
them in the process of identifying
what's the automation should look like
and engage them in the process of
building it we focus specifically in the
automation process on the points of pain
whether that's cost whether that's risk
whether that's delays the pain point
gave us a really solid business case in
order to invest in this technology and
be able to do some automation but beyond
all that we needed the insight we needed
the insight that building a new
technology gave us but we also needed
the insights that the technology is
starting to give us and as we move
forward we anticipate that we will
actually be able to learn from the
technology and improve the allocation
schemes further because you won't simply
be analyzing data in a traditional
statistical fashion we'll be able to
analyze the data that is out in our
allocation schemes and improves them in
real time to save ninh through the lives
of others because that's what this is
really all about this isn't about the
technology it isn't about how easy and
fancy it all gets it's about how we can
use that technology to contribute to our
core purpose on what we stand for as an
organization at NHS doesn't transfer
we're proud to say that we stand for
hope we stand for life
and we stand for enabling people to do
something extraordinary every day to
save and improve the lives of others to
save and improve the lives of little
girls like this Phoebe who's one of our
blood recipients and the process
automation that we're able to carry out
working with the IBM tools is about
enabling us to do more of that and
enabling us to be more effective of what
we can do what we can be as analyzation
thank you very much
[Applause]
you